[Music]
the Coral Triangle is one of the most
biodiverse places on the planet more
life is found in these waters than
anywhere else in the world but here in
Indonesia destructive fishing practices
and illegal poaching have been
threatening entire species
machaca tanga daddy kombucha me here at
ménage à la comida and bike truce Bionic
millennium when an African diamond
tiara's in barangay a Dominican born
Fortas views sing occurring at the de la
kami they began by Telugu such a
pioneering business model devised by
this couple has not only revitalized the
local economy but is having an
astonishing impact on marine life can
you imagine how different the world
could look if every private enterprise
if every tourism operation protected
some small area of their backyard
[Music]
armored and his team of ocean Rangers
have received reports of turtle poaching
on a nearby island they're in the middle
of missile marine protected area located
in eastern Indonesia
it's a 465 square mile reserve where all
fishing is banned
the success of the marine protected area
depends on the Rangers stopping illegal
fishermen in their tracks they work
alongside the military police who have
the power to make arrests and seized
vessels the fate of any poachers they
intercept will rest in the community's
hands
Camille Walter Campbell we are rapidly
second some of emerita Campo a Tony very
concern see the Rangers are really their
unsung heroes of this marine protected
area there are there day and night rain
or shine doing interceptions with
illegal fishermen getting themselves
into
pretty dangerous situations in order to
ensure that this area is protected and
all this can continue Andrew and Marit
miners first came here in 2005 on a
diving trip they were shocked by what
they found when we arrived on Barbie
Team Island in missile rogem Pat it's
hard to describe the scene of carnage
that we met there was a remnants of a
shark finning camp there were baby
blacktip reef sharks finned floating
around dead in the water it's really a
scene of destruction and devastation
from that moment we decided we really
had to make a stand and protect this
area and stop those sharks getting
slaughtered they petitioned the local
village leaders to lease them the land
and surrounding waters and in a bold
plan to save this ecosystem created a
marine protected area that would be
sustainably funded by a luxury eco
resort
when we first started building on the
island every night when we looked out
onto the horizon it was full of lights
from fishing boats these people were
illegally decimating the reefs and the
fishing stocks of the local community
[Music]
Andrew and Moritz challenge was to
provide an economic alternative for the
hundreds of villagers who rely entirely
on the ocean what we did was create a
whole new set of economic opportunities
for the local people we employ over 200
people and all those people are getting
their income from non extractive work
our Mads has been working as a ranger
for two years patrolling the reef and
carrying out anti poaching missions like
this but like many people in this area
he hasn't always been a conservationist
he's gone from catching fish to catching
fishermen because ideas and missile was
15 seiyya
Pournami JD's alicetin million bamboo
Rick and hewed and the taro goth
Delhomme say hurry miss Aminta
pozzolanic or Hugh this area is one of
the most commonly targeted by turtle
poachers armored thinks he spotted
something
this Beach is a popular nesting site for
green and hawksbill turtles both of
which are endangered the turtles are at
their most vulnerable when nesting on
the beach yeah it does hurt to salah
satu japanese emperor berteus madam Jami
they deploy in a rapid our own pen yo
satu dua tiga impart lima and now to you
de lapin nan de cine tempeh tempeh
Lupita jaga BR John Sarang Sarang when
you need the most autonomous Erica data
when you online only one in 1,000 sea
turtle hatchlings will survive to
adulthood so it's vital that every
single egg is protected it's not long
until armored spots some telltale signs
of poaching in Shepparton Ellen Yin dong
Cassini simcha made America a new guinea
seems like this are all too common as
animal populations inside the protected
area continue to grow so does the threat
from poaching than say you guys on @cd
myriad when you young the bullet rusty
BR can be attached panting yeah well the
flat from illegal fishermen is always
present
over the last 12 years the area has seen
an extraordinary transformation the fish
biomass has increased in some areas by
six hundred percent and there are now 25
times more sharks inside the reserve
than just outside
bearing in mind the incredible explosion
of fish biomass this place has become
more and more attractive for those
high-end tourists to visit it's not only
been incredibly profitable for the
marine environment the protection we're
doing it's become incredibly profitable
for the business now guess I'm actively
choosing businesses that are supporting
conservation and social programs
globally coral reef dive tourism is
valued at thirty six billion dollars
annually if Andrew and Moritz business
model can be replicated it could provide
hope for huge areas of our ocean if you
look at the economics of conservation
versus extraction it's very clear that
there are incredible benefits to be
reaped from protecting natural resources
sharks and mantas are worth so much more
alive than they are dead the business is
only possible because of buy-in from the
local communities and government at 465
square miles
Mizell marine protected area protects
only a fraction of Indonesia's waters
but Andrew and Merritt hope that the
story of their success may encourage
others as they fine-tune their business
model over the next few years they want
to pitch to hotel chains and tourism
operators to start similar ventures our
dream scenario is that missile becomes
the gold standard for private enterprise
doing conservation this is what we need
in the future we need private
entrepreneurs doing conservation work
and protecting natural resources as the
central asset of their business our mats
community has been fishing these waters
for centuries thanks to the marine
protected area they're now making more
money than they ever did as fishermen
and their way of life has been
safeguarded for generations to come
nagatomi bongo karna the Mondamin
the ranger ato program kami
toboggan weaken melon Dunican young
brother diagonal then cyber her up
smoker program you need a package a
bonding and lunch are then beside you
getting parties of our Masha rocket
Young's language
[Music]
[Music]
you